翻訳: Mari Arimitsu
校正: Shoko Takaki
皆さんこんにちは
レーシングドライバーの井原 慶子です
私は普段 時速330キロで
― 普段は時速60キロで走る公道を ―
レーシングカーで走っています
命の次に大事なのが
このヘルメットです
150万円します（笑）
まずですね 私は昨年まで３年間
世界最高峰のル・マン24時間レース
と言うものに出ていました
こちらはですね
今見ていただければ分かる通り
強靭な男性ばかりです
この中にですね 女性は
私一人しかいません
なぜ私一人しかいないかと言うとですね
まずレースでは男女の区別がないんです
この区別がない所でですね
ただ運転しているだけのように
見えるんですけれど
もの凄い体力がいる
スポーツなんです
ただ運転しているだけのように見えても
カーブを曲がるときは
自分の体重の５倍ぐらいの重力
要は５Gがかかってくる ということは
大体300キロぐらいの重りで
こう「どすこい」と
お相撲さんから
押されているようなもの
自分の この全身の筋力で
グッと こう耐え抜くわけですね
なので心拍数が
大体170以上になると
オリンピックのマラソン選手が
42.195キロを走る時が170で
私たちがレースをやる時は
大体170から210の領域で走っています
こんな男性ばかりの世界選手権に
じゃあなぜ私が ここまで
到達できたかと言えば
沢山の人達に助けられて
そして 自分の感情を武器にして
ここまで これたからだと思います
昔はこんな職業をやっていました（笑）
こんな形をした水着を着て
ビフォー・アフターというように
なってしまいましたが
やっぱり300キロオーバーの
風を受けて走ってますとですね
沢山シワも増えます（笑）
今はアフターになってしまいました
そんな中ですね 私は大学生の時に
モーグルスキーという競技をやっていて
その合宿費用を捻出するために
モデルのアルバイトを始めたんです
当時は自分にものすごく自信がなくて
スポーツも勉強も何もやり遂げたことがなくて
そして この先自分の
夢もなくて目標もなくて
どうしたらいいんだろう？という風に
すごく自分に葛藤していました
でもある日ですね モデルの仕事の一つとして
レースクイーンと言うのがあって
こう傘を持って サーキットに
行ったところですね
すごい自分と真逆の人を見たんです
「人間の本気」を出している人です
私は毎日毎日 大学生までダラダラ
生きていたんですけれど
メカニックやエンジニアや
レーサーがですね
自分がネジを締め間違えたら
人が死んでしまうかもしれない と言うような
人間の本気
ものすごい責任感と緊張感
そういったもので仕事をしている
というのを感じて
ハッとさせられました
私も生まれたからには
生きているからには
自分の頭と体の能力 全部を
発揮してみたいという風に思ったんです
そしてですね ４年間で１千万円を
アルバイトで貯めました
ローソンでアルバイトしたりとかですね
スーパーマーケットの
惣菜屋さんのアルバイトとか
モデルもやってましたけれど
それ以外にも お中元やお歳暮を宅配する
アルバイトなんかで１千万円貯めた
そしてようやく25歳の時に
レースデビューできることになったんです
ところが今は世界選手権に出るような
プロのアスリートはですね
大体15歳ぐらいにもう出ていると
私は25歳に初めて そのスポーツを
始めたと言うことで
10年も20年もスタートが
遅れているわけです
私はですね この年レースに
デビューした人の中で
最もこれは負けていないと
思うものがあったんです
それは「覚悟」です
私はまず女性であること そして
お金を自分で貯めたと言うことでですね
すごい覚悟を持っていました
なぜなら「レーサーになりたい」と言うことで
沢山の人に「私レーサーになりたいんです」
と相談したら―
100人に話すと 大体99人は
私のことを馬鹿にしてきました
「女にできるわけないでしょ」と
「貴女はだって運転免許も
まだ持ってないでしょ」と
（笑）
確かに私はレーサーになりたいと思った時
免許を持っていませんでした（笑）
「あんた免許持ってないでしょ
何言ってるの」
それで 「レースクイーンの戯言でしょ」
もしくは「愛人でも作ればお金をもらって
レースでもできるんじゃない」と
小馬鹿にされたものでした
でも 免許も取って 勉強して
理論も技術も勉強して
お金も貯めて 自分でここまで頑張ってきた
「よし この一年で絶対やってやろう」
と言う気概がありました
そこでその気概からですね
日本では優勝できて
世界戦のイタリアのレースに
行けたんですね
そうしたら この写真のように
グリグリ 私の後ろを押してきたりとかですね
真横から突っ込んできて
私を飛ばそうとする人がいるんです
それで「何するんだ」と
「これフェラーリだぞ」と
（笑）
私は１千万円貯めたと
１千万円でフェラーリって買えないんですよね
２千万、３千万します では私がどうやって
フェラーリを買ったのか と言えばですね
オンボロで４人が大クラッシュして
炎上したことがあるフェラーリが
中古でヤフーに
売ってたんですね（笑）
それを買ったんです
要はそれのオンボロで走っている
残り250万円しかない
と言うことはですね
並々ならぬ覚悟な訳です
なのに250万円の内
ここで100万円のバンパーを
ブシャーと潰されたわけです
「100万円どうしてくれるんだ！」と
すごく思ったわけですね
そう言った怒りからですね
自分が今まで感じたことがないような領域で
運転できることを知ってですね
（笑）
この時 初めてゾーン “Zone”
と言うものを知りました
おかげで世界の120台の
フェラーリの中で２位になれたんです
シューマッハに表彰された
この時に「世界一の人に会った」と
私は「どうやったら世界一になれますか？」
と聞いたんですね
そうしたら「きっとこれから
苦手な事とか 君が好きじゃない事とか
弱さが壁となって ボーダーとなって
現れてくるよ」と
「それを自分で工夫して考えて
そして感情をモチベーションにして
一つずつ乗り越えなさい
もし もうレーサーを辞めなきゃいけない
と言うような時が来たら
僕の事を思い出しなさい
もうこれ以上やる事ないかなと
僕がささやいているのを思い出せ」と
「これ以上やる事がなければ もう辞めていい
そうじゃないんだったら どんなに不利な環境
どんなに不条理な環境でも
自分から順応していけ」
というアドバイスをもらって
私はイギリスに行く決意をしました
なぜイギリスに行ったかというと
モータースポーツの本場だからなんです
ここでもですね 後ろから
ガンガン押されたんです
この張本人は今 F1で走っている
キミ・ライコネンです（笑）
グイグイ押してきて
なんだイタリアでも押されれば
イギリスでも押される と
ところがイタリアで押された時は
２位になりましたけれど
ここではビリになりました
「うわーレベル高いな」と
もの凄く恥ずかしかったし悔しかったし
あまりにも高いレベルに飛び込みすぎて
私は もう恥ずかしくて
どうしようもなかったんです
ところがやっぱり
押されている時にですね
「なにを」と思ったり 「悔しい」と
すごく頭に血が上った時に
なぜか凄い運転ができることを
また経験しました
翌年フランスのレーシングチームに所属して
また押してきたんですよね（笑）
車を停めているのに後ろから押してくる
どんな人種だと
日本ではこんなパーキングは
あり得ないですよね
３センチでも傷つけたら
日本人だと「あっ」と言うのに
こんなんで ズリッとやって出て行くという
考え方の違いに驚きました
そしてチームに入っても
やっぱり同じでした
やっぱり人種が違ったり
住んでいる所が違うので
価値観が全然違う
と言うことでですね
もの凄いエンジニアと言い合いになったり
それが理解できなくて孤立したり
そしてついには体力がないので
集中力がないと言うことで
スピンをして よくクラッシュをしていて
「あと２回クラッシュしたら君は解雇だ」
と言われたんです
崖っぷちの覚悟が出てきました
そして私はスポーツ科学研究所に
入れられちゃったんです
もう慶子には最後[はここ]しかない
と言うことでですね
トレーニングをしろと言うことで
私は毎朝20キロ走って
100キロその後 サイクリングをして
２時間半筋力トレーニングをして
最後25メートルプールを100回泳ぐ
これが１日のトレーニングメニューでした
これを週に３回から４回やらないと
レーシングカーを早く
走らせることができないと言うことで
毎日やっていました
そこからゾーンに意識的に
入ることを覚えたんです
どんな時でも私はゾーンに
入れるようになってきたんです
まず食事で感情をコントロールする
食事の中でも 例えば明日私が優勝したら
チャンピオンになれるとなるとですね
興奮して寝られないわけです
10時に床についても
４時に寝つけて６時までしか寝てない
要は２時間しか寝てないとなると
頭も脳も胃腸もですね
もの凄くぐったりしちゃっていて
消化が悪い
そんな時 翌日サーキットに行って
レース前に何をするかと言えば
歩いて行って
そこのシェフに頼んでですね
チームメイトやライバルには
絶対内緒にして欲しいけれど
私実は２時間しか寝ていないんだ
だから赤飯を200グラム
すごくよく柔らかくして
レースの２時間45分前に
持ってきてくださいと頼みます
そうするとパッと
２時間45分前に持ってきてくれて
ぱーっと塩をかけます
そこで食べます
そうするとレース前に ちょうど
消化が終わったなという形になります
なぜ そこまでしなければ
いけないかと言うと
お医者さんとか栄養士も
帯同していますけれど
私の消化速度は
私にしか分からないからです
こういう風にですね
糖質と言うのは
例えばスパゲッティーや蕎麦や
うどんよりもですね―
加工して精製した食品よりも
パッと投げたら芽が出るお米と言うのはですね
ものすごく長く集中力が続いて そして
感情をコントロールしやすいと言うことで
こういった食事で
コントロールしたりしています
そして更に じゃあ
レース前音楽を聴く
音楽で副交換神経と交感神経の
バランスをですね 両方とも増幅させると
ゾーンに入りやすいと言うことが
分かってきました
そして筋肉で血流を操る
大きな筋肉と言えば お腹とか
背中とか太ももがありますが
この大きな筋肉を こう動かすとですね
血流が否が応でも頭に行きます
「頭にきた！」と言う表現がありますが
何が頭に来たんでしょうか？
血液ですよね
頭にきた時に
やる気がない人はいませんよね
それと同じようにですね 人間
頭に十分血液が回っている時と言うのは
どんなに疲れていてもやる気が出てきて
モチベーションが出てくると言うことで
そういったことでも感情を
コントロールできる
そして最後に シーズンの最後に
もうこれ以上 回復が間に合わない―
体力の回復が間に合わないという時にはですね
香りでコントロールすることもあります
要は鼻は脳に一番近いからですね
なのでもの凄くダイレクトに
感情をコントロールできると言うことで
最終的にヨーイ・ドンと
グーンとレースする時はですね
もう千分の一秒単位で
判断していくわけです
この時にですね 本当に千分の一秒単位で
判断するには 大脳皮質と呼ばれる
考える脳をシャットアウトして
そこを飛ばして考えないようにするとですね
手足のように車が動くんです
こういった神経系の
コントロールも色々覚えました
そして更にこういう戦いになると
必ず終わった後 負けたドライバーは
「お前女性だから危ない
運転するなよ」って言ってきます
そういったことをですね 今度は利用して
私はアジア人のよく分からない女性だから
気をつけようと言うような形で
皆がしてくれますので
そういったことを活用したり
そして時速330キロオーバーでですね
グーッと走っている時―
ストレートの時は
ドライバーというのは こう余裕があって
首を回したり 手を回したり
大きく深呼吸したりしてですね
心拍数を落とそうとして
要は男性ドライバーでは
そこまですることもないけれど
女性だから やっぱり体力が無いですから
そこで ぐーっと心拍数を
ストレートの内に縮めておいて
カーブで集中すると言うような
工夫をどんどんしていくとですね
このようにですね 感情を何ででも
コントロールできるようになってきました
そして要はアスリートというのは
体は心からコントロールして
そして心は体からアプローチして
要はご飯や水なんかでアプローチして
コントロールしています
そして遂にレースデビューした当時の夢だった
イギリスF3 最も熱いと呼ばれた
アイルトン・セナがF1に行く前に
乗っていた イギリスF3に到達したんです
でもたどりついた夢は
とっても一瞬でした
たどりついたと思って 今まで
何年間もずっと男性と一緒に肩を並べて
世界転戦してきたので
体に無理があってですね
１年の内 200日以上は 38度以上の熱が
出るようになっちゃったんです
すべての体に斑点が出てきてしまったり
目が真っ黄色になってしまって
「ああ これはもう運転どころじゃない
スポーツどころじゃない」
という状況になっていました
そして私は無念にもですね
イギリスを後にしなくてはいけなくなりました
要はドクターからストップはかけられない
ドクターストップはかけられない
なぜなら君がどれだけ気概を入れて
ここに来ているか そして―
どんな責任感を持って どんな予算を
背負ってここに来ているか分かっているから
ストップはかけられないと
でもこのままやったら来年命はないよ
という風に言われて
帰国してレーサーを
辞めることにしました
この時はですね 私のマネージャーだった
マイクと言う男が空港まで送ってくれました
送ってくれる時に
「慶子 よくやったよ
自分の夢 到達したじゃないか
君は多分夢に到達しかけたから
もっと上の夢を見ていると思うけれど
一代でそこまで成し遂げられるほど
歴史は早く動かない」という風に言われて
自分を納得させて
ロンドンのヒースロー空港から
こう自分の飛行機が
飛び立った瞬間ですね
もう止めどなく
涙が溢れたのを覚えています
そんな中 家に帰ってきて 結婚して
そして 私病気ですけれど
日本の人達に助けられてきたんで
何か日本人に恩返しできないかと思って
じゃあ病気だけど
身近な所からと言うことで
近所の子ども達 100人程に
英語を教えることになったんです
その頃はですね
病気を治すのに大変で
トイレにも夜中に20回ぐらい
行かないといけないぐらい病んでいました
ところがこの世代の違う
そして元気な彼らとですね
触れ合っていると
無限大の可能性を感じて
段々元気になって ４年かけて
本当の健康を取り戻しました
そしたらですね やっぱり健康になってくると
「またやりたい」って（笑）
思っちゃったんですね
それで やろうと決めて
今度は世界最高峰までやろう
と言う風に決めました
ところが４年間もブランクがあった
アスリートにですね
世界転戦の費用をサポートするような
企業は一つもないわけです
なので ずっと企画書を書いて
そして何百社にも渡しに行って
そして昼間はトレーニングして
日本が夜になれば
ヨーロッパが朝になりますので
各チームとSkypeで交渉して
３時間睡眠で毎日毎日やっていきました
そして到達した―
やっとたどり着いた世界最高峰
ル・マン24時間レースと言う
世界最高峰のル・マンの勝利の女神は
私を受け入れてくれるか
残念ながら
受け入れてくれませんでした
私は一周も走れなかったんです
私のせいではありませんけれど
第一ドライバーがですね 走っている時に
他のドライバーにクラッシュされてしまって
私が走る番が回って来なかったんです
「私は何をやっているんだ」と
３時間睡眠で企画書を書いて
たくさん回って
トレーニングもして 交渉もして
もの凄いお金を集めてここまで来て
走れない 一周も
何をやってるんだ
驚きました
こちらにぶつけられた張本人が
苦そうな顔をして（笑）
本当は勝利のために用意した
シャンパンをですね
「まあいいよ、許す」って言うことで
この時は真っ赤になりながら
呑んだくれましたが
その後ですね 悔しくて
ル・マン24時間レースのレースが
ずっと続いている中でですね
私はそこでコテッと寝て
朝を迎えてパッと起きたら
まだずっと車が走っている
要はまだゴールを目指して
走っている車がいると言うことを知って
もの凄く悔しかったし
涙を流しました
それで２年目 また挑戦しました
与えられたのは３周だけでした
ル・マンの女神って酷だなと思いました
いきなり車の調子が私が乗る直前に―
第一ドライバーの時から
ガタガタガタガタ言い出して
私が乗った時には もう300キロだと
飛び跳ねるような不具合が起きて
リタイアしました
そこでですね もう２回目でこんなに
２年も続けてこうだと
主人が慰めの言葉を
言ってくれました
「ル・マンの主は
男神なんじゃないか？
男神だから
嫉妬しているんじゃないか？
唯一の女性が成功することに
嫉妬しているんじゃないか？」という風な
慰めの言葉をかけられた時に
もう一年頑張ろうと思いました
（笑）
そして３度目の正直
このようにパレードでは
百万人の人が集まりますので
女性は私一人ですので
皆さん声援を送ってくれます
私はもうAKB48のセンターかなって（笑）
思うほどですね―
勘違いしてしまうほどですが
ル・マンに到達した 今回は
とにかく全てを賭けようと言うことで
情熱がたくさんの人に広まりました
初めはですね どんなチームに入っても
どの国のチームに入っても
アジア人の女性？ 大丈夫なの？
本当に運転できるの？という目で見られます
でもそこはしっかり走って
そして そう思っている方にもですね
自分からコミュニケーションをとって
時間と言葉をゆっくりゆっくり
丁寧に重ねていくとですね
情熱と言うのは やっぱり広がっていって
何倍何十倍の火に燃え盛ります
そしてその火はですね
このように現れます
例えば 私が事前に
血液検査をしていて 鉄分が少ないとなると
私のいとこの管理栄養士の
なっちゃんはですね
ヒジキを用意してくれたり
そして逆にフランス人のチームでしたので
フランス人のチームは
よし慶子は日本人で頑張っている
鉄が足りないと言うから
降りてきてガンと座ったら
盆栽を置いて休ませて（笑）
鉄瓶でお茶を入れて 鉄を飲ませて
最後入り口にはですね―
次に私の番があって乗り込む時には
心にも鉄を入れてやろうと言うことでですね
こういった兜を置いてくれるというですね
（笑）
このような 要は心遣い
ホスピタリティーを受けました
そして330キロで走って
何時間も走ることができた
３周でも１周でもない
でも大雨が来たんです
この時にフランスのチームというのは
女性活用の先進国ですから
私をすごく巧く
上手に起用してくれました
私は大雨、日の入り、
日の出担当だったんです
要は「もの凄く危ない所は
全部慶子が行け」と言うことなんです
（笑）
日本では危ない、女性は止めておこう
と言うことになりますが
向こうは逆でした
女性ならではの やはり五感を使って
いつも冷静に走れる
感情もコントロールできる
そしていつも必ず
同じラップタイムで来れる
ちょっとした敏感な気温とか湿度の変化も
感じて開発できると言うことで
こういった所を任せてくれました
そして遂に３度目の正直で
アジア人初、女性初で完走し
その後のル・マンシリーズでは
世界の女性で初めて
総合優勝することができました
そして もう一つ
大きなレースが私にはありました
16年間を賭けてきたレースです
富士スピードウェイで行われた
日本グランプリの凱旋レース
この時に私は並々ならぬ覚悟で
行ったにも関わらず
若くて綺麗で でも新米の女性を
投入してきたんです 私に
私は女性の活動を推進しておきながら
「えーっ」と思ってしまいました
（笑）
なぜかと言えば 私がこの16年間で
一番大事だと思っているレースに
どうしてこんな新人で女性の
力が弱い人を付けてきたんだと
それで案の定 私のシートベルトを
締めたらユルユルなんです
もうどう考えても死んでしまいます
そこでですねフランスのチームは
凄いなと思ったのが
リーダーがこうテクテクと来て
「よしキャサリン
あんまりちょっと力入らないな
これじゃあ時間がかかっちゃうから
ピットストップに時間かかっちゃうから
こっちからマイケルも一緒に手伝ってくれ」
よしヨーイドンと 二人で引っ張ったら
カチッといつもと同じタイムで
[締まった]んですね
「よしキャサリンは他の所で
もの凄い役に立っているし
キャサリンがいることで
色んな違う考え方や工夫が出てきて
効率的に開発できるようになった
キャサリンを大事にしていこうや」
っていう風に言われてですね
凄いなと 私は自分が思ったことが本当に―
乏しい発想だったなと思って
学びました
ところがやっぱりキャサリンが
活躍してくれたことによって
私は何と世界女性初で この世界選手権の
表彰台に上ることができたんです
女性のパワーって凄いな
という風に感じました
そこで学んだので日本に帰ってきて
私は今年たくさんの女性に
活躍できるような環境ができないかと思って
年齢や国籍やキャリアと言う 全ての
ボーダーを取り払ったオーディションをして
たくさんの自動車産業で働きたい
と言う女性を募集したんです
なんと18歳から68歳の方が
応募してきたんです
そして訓練では
今10代から50代までの人がいて
実は明日 その10代から50代の人達が
監督としてレーサーとしてエンジニアとして
皆デビューすることになりました
そして最後に私は
じゃあなぜレースをしているのって
よく聞かれます
なんでそんなことやってるの？と
それはですね やはり
もの凄く自分がやりたいと思って
本気で臨んだことに対しては
結果が もし成功しても もし失敗しても
それは大きく感情となって
跳ね返ってきます
もの凄く悔しいと思ったり
凄く嬉しいと思ったり
その感情こそが人生の
生きる原動力だという風に思っています
そしてそれを一人だけじゃなくて
たくさんの人と共有できる
要は皆で頑張って「 やったね！」とか
「あぁ安心した」とか 「緊張した」とか
そういった気持ちをですね
感情を皆で共有できると言うことは
本当にお金には変えられない価値がある
と言う風に感じています
そして やっぱり私は生死をかけて
そして千分の一秒をかけて走ってきました
一番 皆さんにお伝えしたかったことは
やっぱり自分で心の中に
自分自身で作ったボーダーや
もしくは―
たくさんの人達の正義がぶつかり合って
できたボーダーというのもですね
一つずつ 私自身も工夫して
乗り越えていきたいと思いますし
皆さんと一緒にですね
乗り越えていきたいと思っています
“You only live once”と書きましたが
一度きりの人生
思いっきり生きたいと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）